[Musique]
dans une contrée lointaine appelé ville
du coin vivent des carrés et des
triangles l'écart et les triangles ne
sont pas fondamentalement différent
après tout tous ont des formes
géométriques et comme le dirait le
président du collectif carré d'as
certains de ses meilleurs amis sont des
triangles de même le porte-parole de
l'association musicale des triangles
aime rappeler que les carrés sont des
formes comme les autres quand la
république de ville du coup en fut créée
carré et triangle vivaient en harmonie
il allait tourner psycho fréquentaient
les mêmes centres commerciaux étaient
voisins les uns des autres chacun voyait
les bons côtés de votre tout allait bien
certes de tout le temps il arrivait que
quelques carrés se retrouve seule au
milieu d'une foule de triangles ou vice
versa
le carré et triangle n'aime pas se
sentir en si faible minorité
personne n'aime être stigmatisé bonjour
le juge m² découvrit que sa femme était
enceinte mètre carré se dit qu'il était
temps de déménager sa femme et lui
trouvèrent deux très beaux appartements
les deux appartements a été aussi beau
l'un que l'autre ne savait pas comment
les départager
c'est alors qu'ils se faire la remarque
que lors d'une visite de l'un des
appartements
il avait rencontré d'un immeuble trois
triangles et un carré l'immeuble
était-il majoritairement triangulaire
cette suspicion fit pencher la balance
de mètres carrés vers l'autre
appartement m² n'était pas anti
triangulaire ils pensaient juste à son
futur enfant ait préféré que celui ci ne
devienne pas le seul carré dans une
classe de clients moi même j'étais l'un
des deux seuls asiatique de mon école
primaire et on n'a cessé de me demander
si l'autre asiatique était mon frère non
c'était comme ça je connaissais même pas
ces petites remarques comme les chinois
xin coque ou l'autre jackie chan c'est
pas méchant c'est agréable surtout quand
ça arrive encore et encore
personne n'aime être stigmatisé du coup
la décision de mètres carrés je la
comprends
j'aurais fait pareil ce désir de ne pas
être stigmatisés parfaitement innocents
mais les conséquences sont dévastatrices
de temps à autre les formes ont la
possibilité de déménager mais personne
n'aime déménager du coup en général les
formes ne déménage pas à moins que à
moins qu'une forme se sentent isolés des
siens elle se dit alors qu'ils
pourraient être l'occasion de vivre
autrement et de ne plus être une
minorité stigmatisé au milieu de formes
différentes
c'est ainsi qu'au fil des années dans
ville du coin
on voit des formes quitté des quartiers
où elles sont très minoritaires pour
rejoindre des quartiers où elles ne sont
plus très minoritaire chacun de ces
déménagements est parfaitement innocents
et justifiable personne n'aime être
stigmatisé mais quelques années plus
tard ville du coin est désormais une
ville divisée n'y trouve des quartiers
très nette délimitée par les formes
qu'ils habitent
l'écart est vive entre eux et
développent leur propre patte d'oie les
triangles ne semaine plus au carré et
n'en connaissent que des stéréotypes et
bien du coup on n'est pas seul dans ce
cas toutes les villes d'un côté on
assister à la même ségrégation sociale
encore et encore
il ya bien des villes qui ont essayé
d'écrire des lois favorisant le mixage
sociale mais rien n'y fait
encore et encore ces villes se sont
divisés ne s'agit pas là d'un résultat
humain politique ou idéologique s'agit
d'une sorte de résultat mathématique
quand chaque individu ne veut pas être
en minorité extrême la société se
déchirent inéluctablement et le
communautarisme devient extrême alors
j'imagine à ce résultat mathématique par
des déménagements et toutes manières
sion est en fait inspirée de
l'excellente pages web
denis chick s éveillera tu que je vous
recommande très fortement aux vitres ou
volontairement des jeux interactifs pour
mieux sentir ses effets de
communautarisme qui n'est uniquement du
désir de chacun d'eux ne peuvent faire
partie de la minorité extrême il faut
bien voir que la portée de ce phénomène
transcende largement le cadre du
communautarisme géographique
à chaque fois que sur internet un
internaute cesse de participer à une
discussion parce qu'il s'y sent trop
minoritaires ils provoquent d'une
certaine manière la ségrégation
idéologique croissante qui ravage le web
or changer de quartier idéologique sur
internet c'est beaucoup plus facile est
fréquent que de déménager
géographiquement c'est donc pas étonnant
qu'en quelques années seulement
l'internet nous a davantage divisé
géographiquement que ce qui a pu causer
la géographie en plusieurs décennies
alors je ne dis pas ça pour vous faire
culpabiliser mon but là n'est absolument
pas d'être un donneur de leçon puisque
je fais partie du problème j'aime pas
être en extrême minorité moi non plus je
vous raconte tout ça c'est pour essayer
de mieux comprendre l'origine de cette
bipolarisation croissante que l'on
observe dans nos sociétés le problème
n'est peut-être pas tant la liberté
d'expression exacerbée que permet le web
le problème est peut-être davantage le
fait que chaque internaute peut plus
facilement quitter les communautés où il
se sent minoritaires pour intégrer des
communautés où il sentira qu'il fait
partie de la majorité
ce faisant chaque internaute coupe tout
contact avec les idéologies autre que la
sienne
ce phénomène est ce que beaucoup
appellent les filter bugs ou bulles de
filtrage en français c'est filter bold
correspondent à des isolations
idéologique dans le web
elles ont pour conséquence que chacun
d'entre nous se renferme dans un univers
où tout ce que l'on dit tout ce que l'on
entend confirme ce que l'on pense déjà
et nous est alors impossible de remettre
en cause nos convictions et de
comprendre pourquoi est ce que les
autres pensent ce qu'ils pensent c'est
filter dobbels sont en plus exacerbée
par les personnalisations de contenus
qu'offrent les géants du web que ce soit
google facebook twitter ou youtube
de nos jours dès que l'on se connecte à
internet le contenu auquel on accède
nous est délivré sur mesure et à chaque
fois qu'on clique sur un lien qu'on lie
qu'un poste qu'on regarde une vidéo
google facebook youtube vous nous faire
des ménages est encore un peu plus près
de la communauté dont on partage les
idées et un peu plus loin des
communautés qui rejette ses idées alors
beaucoup se sont mis à critiquer google
facebook et compagnie beaucoup disent
que ces géants du web sont la cause de
cette ségrégation idéologique mais il
faut bien voir qu'il ne s'agit là que
d'outils qui permettent aux utilisateurs
de faire plus facilement ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment faire on pourrait
littéralement les appeler des outils
démocratiques puisqu'ils correspondent à
ce que les utilisateurs veulent en effet
puisque chaque utilisateur ne veux pas
faire partie de la minorité extrême pour
ne pas être stigmatisé chaque
utilisateur va vouloir s'éloigner de
ceux qui leur sont très différents et
google facebook et compagnie vont les y
aider d'ailleurs si demain google et
facebook changer radicalement leur
algorithme pour lutter contre cette
ségrégation idéologie
d'autres outils marcherait sans doute
pour permettre à chaque utilisateur de
profiter au mieux de son web
si l'on veut mettre fin à la bi
polarisation idéologique croissant qu'il
nous faut trouver d'autres solutions
des solutions plus fondamental les
solutions qui devraient d'une certaine
manière résoudre également le problème
de ville du coin est la seule solution
semble être de lutter contre le désir de
chacun de faire partie de la majorité
pour lutter contre la ségrégation
idéologique il semble nécessaire de
faire en sorte que la position de
minorité ne soit pas une expérience
gênante embarrassantes ou une et revente
et ça commence par ne pas stigmatiser le
seul carré de la classe encore une fois
si le carré se sont stigmatisés il va
vouloir déménager
et ça ça va causer la ségrégation
idéologie qui pourra aussi moins souvent
donné raison à la majorité simplement
parce qu'elle est la majorité mais tout
ça ne suffirait pas en effet parce que
nos sociétés le web sont déjà divisés
même si les triangles et les carrés et
est désormais un différend à être en
minorité
aucun ne voudra alors déménagé on
assisterait à un statu quo rien ne
modifierait la fracture sociale au
idéologique qui est déjà présente pour
lutter contre la ségrégation il faudra
aller plus loin il faudrait donner envie
au carré au triangle de se mêler les uns
aux autres en particulier il faudrait
rendre plaisante l'expérience de la
minorité
certains égards c'est ce que cherche à
mettre en place la discrimination
positive
mais cette discrimination positive ne
peut pas s'arrêter à embaucher un carré
dans une équipe de triangle vous parce
qu'il ya un quota à respecter cette
discrimination positive doit aussi
consister à rendre l'expérience du carré
au milieu des triangles aussi plaisante
que possible pour le carré pour lutter
contre la ségrégation sociale
il faut aider son prochain surtout s'il
est différent
mieux encore dans l'idéal ce qu'il
faudrait c'est donner envie aux gens qui
sont déjà dans la majorité de ne plus
faire partie de la majorité et de se
retrouver en situation de minorité
il faudrait que chaque triangle et envie
de découvrir un monde deux carrés et que
chaque carré s'intéresse à la manière de
vivre des triangles ce nec ainsi que vis
du coin pourra redevenir une ville
cosmopolite en bonne et due forme
mr fois je vous ai parlé du scrutin de
condorcet randomisée et oui c'était un
énorme placement de produit star pub us
lâchent photos promo pour ceux qui
l'avait pas remarqué les longues c'est
moi même patient c'est pas mal d'entre
vous m'ont demandé à quoi ressemblaient
les loteries de condenser en fait il n'a
pas tant que ça c'est quelque chose de
très riche idée de très simple notamment
parce que la loterie élu par le scrutin
de course et randomisée et une fonction
du graff des duels sans ces poids donc
en fait on est très très peu une fois
qu'on a vu le crash des duels on est
capable de calculer directement la
loterie vainqueur de condorcet et donc
là je vous ai mis les cas les plus
simples qu'on peut trouver ou bien c'est
peu de candidats dans ce cas que deux
candidats est un référendum à la
majorité lorsqu'il ya trois candidats ou
bien il ya un vainqueur de condorcet ou
bien il ya un cycle paradoxe de
condorcet à quincy clés de troyes
auquel cas ce sera forcément un tiers un
tiers un tiers lorsqu'on a quatre
candidats on a forcément ou bien un
vainqueur de condorcet ou bien un cycle
un tiers un tiers avec un zéro pour l'un
des candidats
donc on peut pas avoir autre chose que
ça lorsque les quatre candidats en sont
à cinq ou six candidats on a des
configurations qui sont un peu plus
compliquées ou pour soins à 20,40 mars
et déterministe soit un cycle de trois
avec des probabilités un tiers un tiers
un tiers et 00 pour les deux derniers
soit on a un cinquième un cinquième en
5e 25e si on a une parfaite symétrie
tellement ça correspond au jeu pierre
feuille ciseaux les arts et spock
enfin on a une dernière possibilité
c'est compliqué qui correspond à un
tiers un tiers un de viam aut 9e
après bien sûr qu'on ya plus de
candidats on peut avoir des goûts et des
configurations encore plus compliqué
mais souvent quand il ya beaucoup de
candidats mais une élection
présidentielle à douze candidats par
indépendants sont alternativement
pertinente en fait il ya beaucoup qui
vont perdre beaucoup dehors duel face
aux gros candidats du coup il ya
beaucoup qu'en fait ils vont avoir
profité 0 on va se retrouver avec un top
des candidats qui seront sans doute au
pire dans un cycle de 3 mais très
souvent il y aura un vainqueur
déterministe en tout cas aujourd'hui
c'est avec les données d'aujourd'hui il
y aura quasiment toujours un vainqueur
de présence et déterministe et encore
une fois les arguments théoriques pour
le déduire du fait notamment qui a une
ligne
gauche droite dans le cas général est ce
qu'il ya quand même une façon de
calculer les loteries de condorcet alors
oui et j'en ai parlé dans l'épisode un
record malheureusement c'est un calcul
assez difficile qu'il faut faire pour
résoudre un système d' inégalités dont
on sait qu'il ya une solution mais du
coup fossiles comme de manipuler les
choses bien un algorithme pour se faire
connaître
comment du simplex mais généralement les
algorithmes de programmation linéaire
montrer qu'ils sont pauline au mieux en
le nombre de candidats donc en pratique
si à dix candidats se sera vérifiable à
la main il faudra faire pas mal de
calcul et ça notamment c'est intéressant
par opposition au jugement majoritaire
qui bizarrement fait le jugement
majoritaire requiert davantage le vote
électronique que le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés je n'ai juste à enregistrer
pour chaque bureau de vote
kibaki en duel avec quelle marge et
ensuite on peut remonter ces
informations
plus haut ensuite en regroupant toutes
ces informations on pourra construire le
graphe du duel pour l'ensemble du pays
et ensuite on pourrait à calculer à la
main le la loterie vainqueur de
condorcet qu en pratique comme je vous
l'aï dit il y aura sans doute un seul
vainqueur de corse et déterministe du
coup il y aura même pas de calculs
compliqués à faire tout ce que je vous
ai dit c'est en fait plus simple ni veut
calculer des plumes en effort une note
travail mais tout ça c'est plus simple
que le vote alternatif qui est déjà
appliquée en irlande et en australie
donc deux scrutins de condorcet
randomisés il est déjà applicable j'ai
envie de dire avec sans passer par des
technologies du vote électronique
m6 avec le vote est exclu que ce serait
beaucoup plus simple petit peu plus de
précisions par rapport aux côtés
électronique
en fait la grosse difficulté du vote
électronique c
combiner la confidentialité des votes
avec la vérifiabilité du scrutin
n'importe qui peut vérifier que les
conclusions de gains un algorithme qui
calcule le vainqueur ou jeux pas trop
quoi qui calcule le vainqueur le sont
effectivement la bonne conclusion étant
donné les bulletins de vote et combiner
les deux bons parfaitement démontré que
c'est impossible du couffo fait
affaiblir certaines conditions souvent
on va affaiblir plutôt la
confidentialité que la vérification
c'est beaucoup plus important
du coup en termes de confidentialité on
va dire que le scrutin va être
confidentielles à condition de faire
confiance à une certaines entités c'est
souvent parce qu'il utilisait en
pratique et du coup une grosse
difficulté de la recherche en vote
électronique sait à quel point on doit
affaiblir la confidentialité des données
pour pouvoir faire quand même un scrutin
il se trouve que c'est impossible de
l'affaiblir autant que pour le vote à
l'isoloir où là c'est mon niveau de
confiance et l'équipe très très grand
mais est quand même possible de
l'affaiblir pas mal ni en pratique dans
beaucoup de votes n'a pas besoin d'avoir
un niveau de confidentialité extrême je
pense notamment à l'homme si on nous met
dans une petite association et convenir
le président de l'association priori bon
la confidentialité est un peu
importantes mais on peut faire confiance
à google pour la conversion de ce genre
de vote
a priori ce ne sera pas un vêtement
dramatique si les bulletins de vote des
différents électeurs pour une petite
association sont révélées un jour au
grand public dont en tant que ça tout ça
pour dire que en pratique on peut déjà
appliqué ces scrutins dans beaucoup de
cas pratiques et pour répondre à la
question de professeurs culture
précieuse le scrutin de condorcet
rendrait visé a été appliquée par
moi-même pour élire le thème de seconde
série senso roll j'en avais parlé et le
jugement majoritaire lui il a été
appliqué pour lyon sciences je suis un
petit peu déçu que les gens n'aient plus
en parler aujourd'hui alors que c'était
hier minuit en sciences dures à dire par
les aspects
pour l'innocence pour choisir la liste
des intervenants on a choisi d'utiliser
le jugement majoritaire
plus précisément ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on utilisait un google phone demandé
pour chaque proposition d'intervenants
on a noté entrejeu croissance entre 0 et
chaque intervenant et reviennent après
une note médiane mais les meilleures
notes me dionne été sélectionné pour
intervenir alliance et ça c'est déjà un
truc qui 13 applicable aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup des élections il faut
absolument s'est habitué à utiliser ces
scrutins si on veut que l'on finisse pas
réutiliser en politique plus précisément
c'est un dictateur je ne poserai pas
être jour au lendemain comme ça faudra
d'abord l'imposé tu l'utilisé pour
certaines décisions moins importante
pour que les gens se familiarisent avec
sa voir que quand à ce grade est dû à
tous sera forcément un tiers un tiers un
tiers
il faut que les gens seront habitués
avec ça je pense que les gens
accepteront davantage le scrutin de
condorcet randomisés parce qu'ils auront
joué avec pour répondre à la question
d'aller jk ce qu'il faut faire pour que
les gens adoptent du scrutin de
condorcet randomisée à mon sens font pas
qu'ils comprennent les mathématiques
parce qu'ils comprendront jamais vu
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens comprendront
pas les mathématiques cas pas celle que
j'ai présentées dans l'épisode hardcore
mais c'est pas grave
aujourd'hui tout notre système financier
aujourd'hui repose sur des technologies
type rsa dgd cryptographique sont fondés
sur des mathématiques assez sophistiqué
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin de
comprendre comment fonctionne rsa à
chaque fois qu'on utilise un téléphone
et confère un paiement électronique avec
notre téléphone on n'a pas besoin de
comprendre comment tout fonctionne
derrière n'est juste besoin d'avoir
confiance dans la technologie et de la
même façon je pense que pour le scrutin
de condenser randomisés comme pour le
jugement majoritaire faut qu'on ait
confiance aux comment les choses
marchent et on a une certaine
sensibilité au fonctionnement de ces
choses sans forcément comprendre toutes
les mathématiques qu'il ya derrière
bref tout ça pour dire que si vous
voulez mettre fin à la bi polarisation
idéologique croissante a vu dans
l'épisode 2 avoir des politiques sont
plus consensuels et qui tourne beaucoup
moins autour du 10e du vote utile et je
vais encore avoir des discussions
politiques qui sont plus au sujet des
idées à mettre en place en politique
plutôt que au sujet de comment il faut
voter après
c'est à l'est qui est qu'il faut faire
confiance et éviter de parler des
individus damman il me semble que l'une
des façons les plus directs c'est de
contribuer au futur de nos démocraties
c'est en écrivant une application pour
commencer à habituer les gens à d'autres
façons de penser la démocratie
vous avez donné un lien la semaine
dernière vers élections alternative
il y en a d'autres qui font des choses
du genre notamment il ya la contrée
élections qui a d'ailleurs mis révélé
les résultats des sondages qu'ils ont
fait pour le vote alternatif pour que
peut-être les rétifs rêve pas mal de
défauts mais c'est quand même
intéressant d'aller voir les données et
en voix serait vraiment cool que
quelqu'un exploitent ces données pour
voir qui a été le vainqueur de condorcet
pour les votes qui était donné dans ce
sondage
quentin à la chaux puis vannes et deanna
001 font la remarque que ce scrutin
favorise les centristes et ont peur que
du coup ça favorise la neutralité des
choses ou cueille il ya des suspicions
aussi dans les commentaires que ça va
favoriser ceux qui font beaucoup de
concessions et qui ont aucun avis il y
avait beaucoup de choses à répondre à ça
la première chose à répondre c'est que
parfois faire l'expérience pour savoir
faudrait vraiment des données empiriques
pour voir comment les gens se comportent
vis-à-vis d'un changement de scrutin et
voir ce que ça implique globalement oui
ça va favoriser les centristes en tout
cas aujourd'hui ça ferait élire les
partis du centre on a vu que françois
bureau était vainqueur de connaisseurs
2007 et en 2012
alors est ce que c'est une bonne chose
vous voyez bien que c'est une question
très difficile parce que qu'est ce
qu'une bonne chose dépend du point de
vue de la personne qui dit donc ça
dépend des préférences des différents
électeurs et si on est en démocratie ce
qui compte c'est de faire une décision
collective à partir des préférences
individuelles et vous voyez qu'il ya
quelque chose un peu qui se mord la
queue
juger la qualité d'un candidat dépend
des vols des préférences des individus
qui dépend de la manière dont ils
expriment qui l'ont dit les pentes du
scrutin l'argument à la con d'orsay ça
fait de dire bon bah on oublie tout ce
que je veux dire
et on va postuler un principe
fondamental qui est le principe de
marseille qui dit que
suivre l'avis de la majorité notamment
dans le cas où la majorité préfère une
alternative à toute autre alternative
ce principe là j'insiste à nouveau sur
ça c'est le seul que je connaisse
aujourd'hui que je trouve vraiment
convaincant dans la logique de prise de
décision collective ou pour revenir au
cas du centre d'une certaine manière le
centre est en effet favorisé par
condorcet parce que d'une certaine
manière la majorité n'est jamais
vraiment contre le centre si on compare
le centre à quelqu'un qui à gauche bat
majorité va dire à le mec qui à gauche
et trop à gauche la majorité va préférer
à skis à droite de la gauche et la même
façon la majorité va préférer ce qui à
gauche que la droite parce que la droite
correspond pas est-ce que dès qu'on
regarde un peu trop à droite on se
retrouve avec une minorité seulement
qu'ils préfèrent ce qui est trop à
droite
du coup cet argument il montre que la
décision consensuelle décision
finalement majoritaire ça consiste à
trouver un juste équilibre entre la
gauche et la droite et c'est ce petit
argument justifie le fait que le centre
soit d'une certaine manière plus
légitime
il correspond mieux à l'avis d'une
majorité parce qu'ils balancent les
extrêmes et en particulier le centre
n'ai jamais supporté que par un petit
groupe de très grands fans qui prendrait
une décision que la majorité que 80% des
gens seraient contre d'ailleurs en
passant les expériences de rida laraki
sur le jugement majoritaire montre que
le jugement majoritaire favorise tout
autant le centre notamment que les notes
médiane des partis extrêmes sont
extrêmement extrêmement basses et ça
c'est intéressant parce que ça montre
qu'avec une autre façon de penser le
jugement majoritaire
on aboutit thème à peu près la même
conclusion qu'avec un scrutin à la
condorcet à savoir que d'une serre
manière la décision démocratique semble
être plutôt celle du centre que des
décisions des extrêmes à rien d'autre
dans les commentaires qui pensent que du
coup
le centre est la moins pire des disques
des décisions par opposition à ceux qui
seraient préférés je suspecte beaucoup
de gens qui aiment la politique d mais
le fait qu'ils aient une opposition
gauche droite comme ça d'avoir toujours
un débat récurrent sur lequel on est
capable de se retrouver d'une certaine
manière mais moi je pense que ce débat
classique ce pin pon où s'opposent
toujours particulier par une autre c'est
pas quelque chose de désirable parce
qu'il détourne l'attention de la
politique sur ce débat classique et sur
l'opposition de classiques plutôt que
vers peut-être des questions plus
importantes de société alors qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si on appliquait
maintenant le jugement majoritaire où le
scrutin de condenser randomisés en
pratique ça je serais très très très
curieux de savoir si une question très
très très difficile ma prédiction c'est
que en effet le centre va avoir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus haut intérêt mais
par indépendance d'alternative
non-pertinence n'importe qui au centre
pourrait vouloir se présenter
du coup on aura une richesse de
candidats au centre qui chercheraient
forcément du coup à se démarquer les uns
des autres attirer l'attention
médiatique vers eux en étant différent
des autres mais du coup les positions
qui permettrait de se dégager
depuis cette position centric ne
pourront pas vraiment être le débat
classique gauche à droite ils seront
obligés d'aller chercher d'autres
dimensions donc des questions qui sont
pas juste sous le plan classique ou
rouge droite où il pourrait partir à
gauche sur certaines thématiques et à
droite vers d'autres disent pratiquer le
soir tard à tourner un peu l'espace des
idées et en particulier on pourrait se
retrouver avec un espace idéologique qui
est pas juste gauche droite qui est pas
unidimensionnel long terme
deux théories des jeunes mais on
pourrait se retrouver avec des questions
de politique qui deviennent du coup
multidimensionnelle et on sent ça serait
beaucoup plus intéressant on parlerait
alors vraiment de candidats qui
correspondent chacun à une version
beaucoup plus démocratique dans ce sens
où ils ont beaucoup plus l'adhésion de
la majorité vis-à-vis d'eux d'autres
alternatives en tout cas je ne doute pas
que les politiciens trouveront des
manières de d'alimenter un débat et je
pense que les questions seront beaucoup
plus du coup sûr le vrai débat politique
que notamment sur les stratégies de vote
notamment l' approche des prochaines
élections il semble que la notion de
diem de vote utile soit plus importante
que jamais le vainqueur de la prochaine
élection présidentielle dépendra
forcément de la manière dont les gens
ont voté et non patentées vrai
préférence les gens elle espère qu'ils
avaient mais cette vidéo à partir du
prochain épisode et jusqu'au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle
on va aborder des sujets moins
théoriques ont reçu gagner un petit peu
démocratique
on va parler notamment des sciences
beaucoup plus empirique qui ont des
conséquences importantes sur le concept
même de démocratie et la politique en
général en particulier la prochaine fois
on parlera des convictions et de la
manière dont athènes se propage
si vous avez aimé cet épisode pensait le
l'ikea le commentaire de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour te manquer le
futur épisode merci au type cordon et
j'espère que vous verrez la prochaine
fois kenyan geoffrey dans une métaphore
routière
si jamais une route est dangereuse la
solution de répression ce serait de dire
cette route nous allons la fermer
l'accès sera interdit
tant pis pour ceux qui habitent là la
solution de la signalisation proposés
par ces journalistes c'était de mettre
des panneaux attention cette route est
dangereuse ni aller car vos risques et
périls
moi la solution que je vais vous
proposer aujourd'hui c'est plutôt celle
de l'éducation des citoyens dans ma
métaphore routière ce serait leur
expliquer le code de la route
comment bien conduit